just what was your attitude going into
the
waking up this morning do you think
there was a good chance you might play
or did you kind of know
it was probably not going to happen and
what was your just what was your
perspective going in
um you know trying to get ready for the
game or
try to do whatever is necessary to put
my body in a position to play
but yeah after i did my treatment i woke
up
did my treatment got my lifting
we talked as a team
physio team and they told me that the
right decision
for me is not to play the game and um
you know i spent
my ankle in the game three i think uh um
did not supposed to play game four play
game four spreading it again
uh so i thought the best
uh the best for me right now is to not
play game five and get ready for game
six so
you know i did my pre-game warm-up i did
everything got my lifting
uh mentality it was a it was a bottle
uh but you know at the end of the you
know you gotta trust your teammates and
that's what we i did that's what i
decided to do
at the last guest
be honest i know it's still you know
fresh but you know what are your
your primary thoughts do you look back
on the season and on your guys's time in
the bubble
uh you know as a team we had fun
i think we enjoy every um minute
second in the bubble uh obviously
playing in a
place like this with no family no fans
uh it was tough obviously that's not
exclusive stuff for everybody
but looking back to the bible obviously
and nobody's gonna be happy you know for
the outcome that uh
we had uh in that playoff run
but at the end of the day you gotta
learn from everything that goes on in
your life in your career and hopefully
we can learn from this and um
you know get better as a team and uh
come back and hopefully you can build a
culture in milwaukee that
for many years that we can come out here
and compete every
single year for uh for a championship
eric name
giannis why do you think this team
didn't end up
looking like the team that they were
before the bubble
like you got you guys just didn't look
like that team that we saw in march
before the stoppage in play why do you
think that is
[Music]
i don't know um if uh if i had the
answer
i would have you know uh
tell my team figure out myself and uh
make uh
our team look the way we look but i
didn't they
we tried to be ourselves there was a
moment that we looked like ourselves in
that boat i think as
uh and individually and as a team wasn't
able to uh
sustain it um having no crowd no fans
and playing not playing for 20 000
people
that gives me
um the bench uh
you know more energy obviously the
effects
because i feel like we have a young team
our benchmark
you know feeds fits themselves through
the energy of the crowd and
fans know that and obviously
being here and playing in front of 20 uh
20 people 20
cameraman's probably affect us a little
bit and uh but i did it as i said that
everybody every team
went through that i think it was just us
but he maybe affected us a little bit
more
dan wiki guys
you guys obviously are super
disappointed with the end result but you
were also
involved in something incredibly
historic while you were here how do you
balance those two
emotions on the way out oh
obviously uh it's hard it's hard to
balance those two um but at the end of
the day what we did
uh i guess uh the game in orlando
speaking of basketball
uh we choose as a team to uh do both
um is it hard to do both yes it's
trying to do both but that's what we
chose as a team
to stand out for something that's bigger
than basketball
said stand up for the son that we
believe and uh
at the same time play basketball but
it's not easy
malika honest we've heard your teammates
over and over again say over these last
two games that they felt that they
needed to do something for you they
needed to support you the way you
supported them
what does that mean to you to have guys
who feel like
what that what they want to do is prove
to you that they can help you
um you know obviously um
you know it's a great feeling and having
uh your team going out there and
trying to play for you also but you know
they don't have to do that for me and
they
they work hard all year long they
deserve to be in this position everybody
i deserve to be this position they
deserve to be in this position so
you know i wanted them i wanted them to
do it for them
you know because as i said you know when
a guy goes down and
we brothers you know we achieve we lose
together
we'll win together and
that's the mentality we have as a team
and uh that's why i love my teammates
that's why i played hard for my
teammates and
they do the same for for me also to have
my bag i have their bed
time for two more let's go to kane
pitman
hey giannis uh you sort of spoke about
the the 24 hours leading up to the game
in the pre-game
um to this point you've been relatively
fortunate i guess not to miss too many
games with injuries when you get to this
game
the season's on the line you're hoping
that they can hang on so maybe you get
an opportunity what what are
some of the emotions and feelings you're
feeling not being able to to do anything
on court
i kind of feel lost to be honest with
you
uh but you know if it's you know if it's
up to me up
i'll play with uh with one like one leg
out
i really don't care but at the end of
the day you know we we have
people in the team that sometimes
they have bigger saving you and they
have to protect you have to protect your
health
no matter what uh and you know it's good
because you know there's a lot of uh
case in uh
in previous cases uh in the past that
um they've put you know the team over
there
the player's health and um you know i
love my organization for that i
appreciate that
um
they protected me but you know i i
wanted to play
everybody you know and to play i know
and play
my coach know i wanted to play but at
the end of the day um
my organization put my health over to
game five and uh
be honest your teammates always talk
about the fact that they feed off of
your energy and then you kind of
reciprocate that back
so i'm wondering what have you learned
what's the
impact maybe on the court or off the
court that
the guys in that locker room have had on
you in this past year
i play i play every game every game
every day i step on the floor every
practice you know i play
my family but at myself end of the day i
represent my teammates um
you know as a player since i was a
little kid i always did that i never
wanted to let my
teammates down and we had great vets
that
were able to uh coached me through this
journey this year and
told me to be more vocal uh
the same whether i'm on the court and i
give them energy and i take energy from
them i gotta do the same thing off the
court uh
uh and it was it was just like
it was it's hard it's hard because as a
person i try to uh
uh be alone be left alone uh but another
day the goal is to always to win a
championship
and uh you can't do that at all you got
to do with your teammates and uh
as i said i had great vets that you know
coached me through this whole journey
and i'll learn a lot from them